ja habe gerade ja vor kurzem so gesagt
ja also wenn das Wetter mitspielt dann
kommen wir auch irgendwie ganz gut über
den Winter na klar wenn der Winter
ausfallen würde wäre sicher noch besser
ich finde wirklich das sage ich jetzt
nicht weil ich Opposition bin sondern
auch bei früheren Regierungen ich hatte
immer viel zu kritisieren es ist wurde
auch sicher manches falsch gemacht aber
ich muss sagen eine Regierung die so
völlig ohne Konzept ohne Plan war in
einer so schwierigen Situation die sogar
immer noch eigene Fehler zusätzlich
machen das finde ich erschreckend und
wenn man seriöse Prognosen für die
nächste Zeit sich an sie die Bundesbank
sagt ja wir kriegen eine beispiellose
Inflation zweistelliger Bereich und
gleichzeitig wird die Wirtschaft
einbrechen Olaf Scholz hat im März den
Bürgern und Bürgern versprochen im
Bundestag das ist keine Sanktion geben
wird die uns mehr Schaden als der
russischen Führung und ich muss sagen
wenn man ihn an dieses Versprechen
erinnert dann müsste er jetzt eigentlich
als Bundeskanzler sofort sagen Stopp wir
machen hier nicht weiter